c'était un 12 janvier il était 16h53
[Musique]
ils pourraient cette école au nuage de
poussière georges noël venait de
reconduire sa femme et ses enfants à
l'aéroport de port au prince
joubert mon désir était allé chercher
ses enfants à l'école je sautais la
voiture qui montent et descendent et
qu'elle steffensen chance y jouait dans
le gymnase de son école secondaire comme
un nuage de poussière qui s'est levé
martin fidèle étudié le droit à
l'université de port-au-prince
tout était à terre dont la mère est à
tomber c'est m
si c'était des morts partout
le 12 janvier 2010 à 16h53 la faille
située directement sous port au prince a
glissé sur 50 km libérant une puissante
énergie accumulés depuis plus de deux
siècles
un des côtés de la faille s'est soulevé
de plus d'un mètre
j'espère comment je suis arrivé à sortir
de la maison
j'ai pas la conscience claire j'avais
tout ce que je pouvais voir cet
installateur qu'ils voulaient sur un
même est évidemment rencontre
la terre tourne et on dirait qu'il y
avait comme bulldozers un sou à faire
travailler latéral du dessous pour ceux
qui étaient là tout semblait irréel
la première image que j'ai vu que j'ai
pas compris tout de suite c'était
c'était un élève du lycée qui sortait
d'école avec la moitié de son crâne a
cassé donc c'était ça ma première image
que je comprenais je comprenais pas en
quelques secondes
trois cent mille bâtiments se sont
effondrés c'était ça puis ça a duré pour
une éternité
c'est ça il des cas c'est ici daniel à
23 ans il faisait de la comptabilité
quand l'école où ils travaillaient s'est
effondré sur lui il a le cou cassé il
est paralysé
il n'y a aucun médicament pour le
soulager
mais je veux parler et carole la cousine
de daniel qui vit à montréal décide de
voler à son secours
j'avais porté des médicaments toutes les
médicaments quitter on vote lui que je
suis capable d'amener jamais tout ça et
vianney les plusieurs collet cervical
arrivée sur place elle découvre son
cousin couché sur le béton devant
l'hôpital en ruines
il y avait des mots à côté il y avait
des malades des prix fort cutri
les adultes quel que soit au calacs
comme tes portes à tous les hôpitaux de
la capitale étaient effondrés
ici on l'avait soigné à même la rue
beaubien dans la cour de l'hôpital tu
avais un coin où on faisait toutes les
opérations des opérations sa anti
douleur ça anesthésie
on s'est écoulé
à moto
au milieu de cadavres oxydé au canada
on ne trouve pas les mots pour décrire
c'est un tambour à ciel ouvert
c'est en bois cette nouvelle
gaël n'a que 13 il doit trouver refuge
chez ses cousins
sur la route ils croisent leurs heures
la dévastation les adultes lui demande
de s'occuper des plus petits il me
disait de cacher les yeux de leurs
enfants qui était plus petit mais je me
suis posé la question de comment je me
suis posé la question de pourquoi moi je
ne vais pas me cacher les yeux aussi
carole ces lieux a pu faire évacuer son
cousin vers un abidal de la floride
mais après des jours d'intenses douleurs
le coeur de daniel a cessé de battre
j'étais proche de proposer des beaucoup
d'épreuves c'était dur plus de deux cent
cinquante mille personnes ont perdu la
vie et trois cent mille ont été blessés
plus d'un million d'haïtiens se sont
retrouvées sans abri une catastrophe
d'une ampleur inimaginable
des souvenirs qui ravive les blessures
sait pas comment faire le day 2
mais cette tragédie